e aí
e quem de você já fez algum teste
vocacional na vida por favor levanta a
mão
ah e quem que vocês teve um resultado
assertivo com esses testes
a resolver bastante isso acontece porque
a maioria das pessoas quando se submete
a um teste vocacional recebem os seus
atributos e não de fato perfil pessoal o
propósito de vida acontece de uma forma
diferente tanto que os testes
vocacionais
se tiver o resultado de quinze por cento
considerados realmente importantes e
e as pessoas que fizeram participar
dessa pesquisa realmente consideram
importantes em uma pequena quantidade
e o mercado atualmente já considere as
espécies completamente ultrapassados e
daí a gente tem a possibilidade de
investigar o propósito o que que é esse
tal de propósito o propósito vem da
palavra vocação é um som significam a
mesma coisa invocação etimologicamente
significa chamado do coração por isso
que muita gente entende que o propósito
significa a essência
com o propósito de vida designa uma base
para a gente conseguir estruturar a
nossa caminhada profissional ele fornece
informações que facilitam as nossas
escolhas na medida em que a gente
executa essa caminhada o propósito de
vida também facilita com que a gente
saia da caixinha e tem a 6 8 carreiras
que os especialistas dizem que nós
teremos agora em diante
oi eu já saí dessa caixinha umas 6 ou 7
horas só que durante esse processo eu
ainda não tinha clareza sobre o
propósito de vida eu estava batalhando
buscando entender no que eu era boa de
verdade então foi muito sofrido foi a
pior dor que eu enfrentei durante uma
vida toda e aí um pouco depois daquela
idade com essa cara eu perguntei para
minha mãe para que que eu tinha nascido
e eu acho que ela não lembro brasil
porque eu faço três tempo porque eu me
sentia
o incompleto eu já sentiu naquela época
que eu tinha uma missão a ser cumprida
eu acreditava que cada um de nós tinha
essa missão e era muito claro para mim
mesmo na minha cabeça de criança eu sei
que pode ser difícil acreditar tão
pequena pensar isso mas mesmo mesmo
naquela época eu entendia que essa
missão era um trabalho a ser executado
foi então que eu comecei a minha busca
por que a resposta não me deu não foi
tão satisfatório ela disse para eu
seguir meu coração eu pensar no meu
coração tá aqui dentro tanto que eu vou
então como assim conseguir isso tudo que
tá aqui em continuar vida buscando
entender o que realmente significava
essa missão porque o sente que cada um
de nós era bom de fato em alguma coisa
na época para vestibular foi
extremamente tenso eu juntei todos os
cabelos que eu perdi um dia para
e os meus pais que eu estava desesperado
fiz o primeiro teste vocacional formatar
jet fiquei mais confuso ainda aí eu vi
que eu não tinha saída eu tinha que dar
um jeito de resolver minha vida e
continue buscando essa resposta 30 anos
depois eu consegui entender o mecanismo
do propósito de vida em 3 passos simples
eu vou explicar para vocês como vocês
conseguem chegar no propósito verdadeiro
e honesto primeiro é entender que o
propósito é o único é seu e que não
adianta vocês perguntarem para ninguém
porque essa resposta tem que vir de
dentro de você
e a gente custa a entender a receber um
elogio simples de como você tá bonita
hoje você agradece faz cara que brigada
mas por dentro ah meu cabelo tá tão bom
assim até isso a gente tem dificuldade
quanto mais
a entender que algo realmente vem de
dentro de você é um conjunto de talentos
e capacidades que forma você como pessoa
e tipo pode combinar numa profissão
ideal que a totalmente a sua caro
e a segunda coisa é justamente olhar
para si história com que isso vai
acontecer você tem que resgatar a sua
história de vida inteira desde a sua
infância mais remota até o momento
presente
o e observa as brincadeiras que você
mais gostava quais as nossas
preferências os seus gostos
e como que você lidava com as pessoas
e o que que você gostava de estudar quem
anda você tá na escola
e quais os papéis você desempenhavam
aquela sua vida adulta porque o
entrelaçar disso tudo vai combinar no
propósito de vida e fazer essa análise
toda é que vai te entregar ali te desejo
uma profissão ideal baseado nos seus
talentos nas suas qualidades inatas nas
suas capacidades naturais cláudio tudo
isso gente a somado a técnica obviamente
e um terceiro passo é ligar todos esses
pontos e ler nas entrelinhas deles
e se uma criança sonha em ser astronauta
não significa necessariamente que essa
será a profissão dela a pergunta certa é
o que significa ser astronauta na cabeça
dessa criança e a partir daí observar
todas as coisas que você conseguiu
desvendar durante esse processo pensava
que a última coisa é um propósito de
vida até então você consegue extrair um
perfil aprofundado de cada pessoa e
naturalmente as habilidades solicitadas
para o futuro do trabalho são extraídas
você entende que você tem toda esse
pacote então este os outros também tem
isso para entregar e desenvolve
resiliência empatia inteligência
emocional porque você tem que lidar com
vários conteúdos emocionais relevantes
para os dois ainda está vivo e
por isso resolvi também uma das
principais preocupações dos
especialistas em futuro do trabalho que
é o sistema de ensino
já estão preocupadíssimos com o jeito
que a educação acontece porque ela não
dá assistência soci emocional ela o
sistema de ensino não transmitir isso
isso sistema de ensino nos faz pudessem
trabalhar um pouco disso com seus filhos
essas habilidades que o futuro dos
trabalhos topete já estariam melhor
resolvidas e o bom disso tudo é que a
cultura de propósito também pode ser
levada para dentro das empresas somado a
técnica
e as empresas podem utilizar isso como o
seu norte assim como no propósito
pessoal e criar métricas baseadas nesse
propósito caso contrário elas não vão
funcionar para que isso tudo seja
mensurado e convertido em resultados as
empresas que trabalham a cultura de
propósito geralmente têm pessoas mais
fiéis a ela pessoas engajadas que buscam
resultados e se sentem fazendo parte
porque elas têm uma causa em comum elas
pensarem a mesma coisa e é o caso da 3m
a 13 é uma empresa aqui está em 6 horas
diferentes atuação tem mais de 600 mil
produtos comercializados
o e distribui seus produtos para mais de
200 países ela começou a cultura de
propósito dela em 1941 quando um dos
fundadores percebeu que era preciso
criar um programa de progresso focado
nas pessoas porque as pessoas são o que
a realidade delas apresentam porque não
a empresa apresentar uma realidade
e com uma causa para ser perseguida e
todo mundo conseguiu engrenar nisso
junto então os líderes da 3m e sempre
lembram os seus funcionários do seu
propósito ea equipe e tem autonomia para
investir em criatividade e inovação e
criar novos produtos para conseguir
crescer cada vez mais e essa equipe de
uma empresa como a trezene naturalmente
se torna mais produtiva porque ela tem
espaço e a empresa abre caminho para que
ela como os riscos de inovar e de
consegui ultrapassar os limites
tecnológicos e necessários para se
adaptar cada vez mais ao mercado
e o propósito tá trazendo para vocês
entenderem o que que é uma causa
verdadeira e que o funciona tanto tempo
é antecipar o futuro criar soluções para
problemas que ainda não existem sendo
assim a gente acaba caindo na questão
das habilidades mais uma vez quando uma
cultura de propósito é bem estabilizada
é bem mensurado naturalmente as pessoas
desenvolvem todas as habilidades que o
futuro do trabalho pede a criatividade é
uma das principais
e depois a mais falar da solução de
problemas complex
o trabalho no grupo que a gente já
deveria saber fazer há muito tempo
gestão do tempo coisa simples
é mas que a gente ainda não faz porque
hoje a gente ainda está acostumada
chegar executar virar as costas e ir
embora e assim ninguém se sente fazendo
parte a gente gosta de sentir integrado
de se sentir fazendo parte não tão que a
gente vive em estribos há séculos até
hoje a gente divide assim por isso
musical esporte porque isso já da
afinidade isso é o que liga a gente e
por que não trabalhar dentro das
empresas
o e criar um clima favorável ambiente em
que todo mundo possa crescer empresa de
trabalho são propósito na medida em que
incentive o talento e as pessoas têm
mais espaço para expor i têm aulas são
de verdade entregando são melhor e quem
sabe um dia a gente consiga criar uma
grande comunidade de pessoas que se
sentem melhor no trabalho entregando que
elas têm de bom completamente
conscientes disso eu gostaria que você
saísse ainda que hoje pensando na causa
que te mole verdadeiramente
é uma causa que move a sua empresa por
quê que a sua empresa foi criada de fato
a invés da entregar um produto
específico para um serviço específico
ela pode ser muito melhor ela pode criar
produtos e serviços baseados em uma
causa o propósito é sempre algo
colaborativo seja a nível pessoal ou no
nível empresarial e eu pessoalmente
entanto que ele também resolve um outro
grande problema o segundo grande
problema segundo os especialistas em
futuro do trabalho
e hoje eles estão extremamente
preocupados porque eles preveem muitos
excluídos dessa revolução tecnológica
pessoas que vão ficar nas suas mesmo se
as empresas trabalham essas inovações
essas habilidades elas vão continuar no
mercado se elas trabalham tudo isso elas
não conseguia incentivar as pessoas a
entregar o seu melhor e menos excluídos
estarão nas ruas eu espero realmente que
você sai daqui com essa pulga atrás da
orelha
oi e a gente possa criar essa comunidade
de todo mundo que entrega isso melhor
daqui um tempo porque as pessoas que
passam por esse processo sempre da claro
alívio de terem tocado um pouco mais
é na sua essência
e você sai tem mais calmas
e consegue
a ter escolhas mais assertivas se sentem
e com menos medo elas perdem elas dizem
que perderam o medo de arriscar isso a
gente vai medo a gente não move além
disso eu pessoalmente acredito que toda
essa revolução tecnológica pede para a
gente se tornar mais humano de coragem
da gente olhar para a gente mesmo com
todos os nossos pontos fortes com as
nossas fraquezas fortalecer os nossos
pontos fortes as nossas qualidades
naturais realmente descobrir quais são
elas olhar para o colega ao lado
eu estou tão elogio incentivar no que
ele é bom de verdade porque isso
estimula a gente buscar mais e nada
disso acontece isso líder não estiver
compreendendo a importância de estúdio
se ele não acreditar nisso ou se ele não
tiver um propósito verdadeiro porque ele
não vai conseguir sustentar a equipe não
traz isso para dentro é o líder que
precisa sempre lembrar os seus
funcionários e chamá-los todos para
batalha de vencer a causa da empresa é
só pela liderança que isso acontece
e não acontece por outro caminho
funcionado sozinho sonhando com isso a
empresa não vai ter uma cultura de
propósito é ao constantemente cultivado
e lembrado deve ser
a atriz é inclusive passou por um
processo de fechamento de fábricas e
descobriram que era porque houve uma
ruptura com propósito deixaram só
algumas unidades abertas e conseguiram
recuperar aquele rendimento no tempo
curtíssimo porque se reconectar com a
propósito eu gostaria de compartilhar
com vocês que esse é justamente o meu
propósito
a dividir essa ideia é multiplicar essa
ideia contar que isso existe
se comunicar que isso é possível e
principalmente
o tanto pessoal quanto empresarial é
tecnicamente aplicável muito obrigada
e aí